miguel cabrero remains on 499 career
home runs he will eye history yet again
here at home against the angels in town
for a three-game series starting tonight
they now get ready to face the 24 year
old native of springville alabama casey
mize
ohtani smacks that one right into center
field that's a good way to start the
series and start the night here in
detroit now he has to contend with
cabrera who's one of the great
pranksters of all first baseman in the
game miggy will mess with you in a in a
fun way pass mvp future mvp i like it
showi otani sitting at 17 stolen bases
hunter wendell stat behind the plate
there he goes breaking ball low tag high
safe you know tony a little slow to get
up looks to be okay and there's long
strides
foot on the base
he's definitely in there
and here comes iglesias
2-2 to iglesias way that i missed big
strikeout for casey mize to away it was
it's you know it's funny he actually
started off the plate
and then still kept
going away from him so we got him to go
for his pitch
that's called they are the pitching baby
and now it's up to brandon marsh
[Music]
3-1 drives that ball into center diving
and he won't get it ohtani around third
washes into third
and brandon marsh with a sinking line
drive
puts the angels on the board well crazy
this game is it goes from you think
maybe they picked them off at seconds
and now a run scored picks up his third
rbi of the year
fastball hard to the plate inside out
nice swing there for marsh
now the payoff
popped it up
to right field for robbie grossman
and mize is through the first after 33
pitches miguel cabrera bets third
chasing 500 and trying to get the tigers
even
for dylan bundy his fourth start since
returning to the rotation
uh nice pitch
caught the corner and caught grossman
got him with a split finger change up
the first baseman number 24.
miguel
[Applause]
down the line lagarus careful oh that's
a terrific catch he had to navigate that
corner slid by it and then up against
the wall made the catch and he's getting
booed for making the catch
second strike out of the night for casey
mize two away
here comes ohtani
and he walks and so he may be running
again
short cautiously there he goes pitches a
strike put on the second base got it
that was a bullet and right
on the mark
that's a great pitch oh it is
throws nunes outside corner at the knees
second strikeout for bundy credit kurt
suzuki on that one too he did a nice job
of keeping that glove right on the
outside corner slider that's why you're
seeing some good pitches early for bundy
fletcher backhand throw oh gorgeous
david fletcher joe mann will tell you
best second baseman in the american
league
2-2
little tapper
mize has it that's going to be a base
hit that is now
not only in the glove has been his
fletch that is
his flesh there another hit another
infield hit 139 hits on the year for
fletch
big lead for fletcher ball in the dirt
and it gets by grinder and bounces all
the way to the on deck circle
oh two
slow tapper to short castro gets one
scopes turn
not even close
and so at the corners
you've got to get this guy home here
from third if you're jack mayfield
and he shoots it right through it into
right field for a hit
fletcher scores
how about that
the 3-0 outside boy dylan bundy suddenly
not even close unable to find the strike
zone with his 90 mile an hour fast ball
to left field base hits
griner will score
jonathan skope puts the tigers on the
board all those baseline balls and what
a nice buggy whip for jonathan scope
nice little bug you have to drive in
that run that was a big run because
well you know it's coming up
and he gets caught looking
tigers do score a run though here in the
third they get to within one against
dylan bundy and the angels as we head to
the fourth
there we go reiner drills one into the
left field corner
he will dig for second and grayson
grinder has himself a one-out stand-up
double good swing grayson brown has been
on twice tonight two away for robbie
grossman the glove above the belt checks
the runner two-two swing to line driving
to right field base hit over the glove
of fletcher grinder around third he will
score without a throw
robbie grossman delivers it two outs and
ties the game at two
well good good quality hitting right
there nice buggy whip
we
kind of feared he was going to go back
to his go-to pitch so did robbie he
stayed on the ball
barrel the bat out in front and that
means miguel cabrera gets to bat with
two men on the big man
everybody rises as one when miguel
cabrera steps to the plate
doesn't get the chance
a walk to love the bases would usually
be greeted with a cheer not here
first pitch swinging and he pops it up
to shallow center
long run for marsh he's in and he makes
the play
last time up carver didn't get anything
close and drew a walk
and they walked him
wanted that last pitch
and here's myers a really nice outing
his last timeout
and he gets him slider nunez
strikes out
[Music]
in out and in 94 95 94
at 95.
suzuki was setting up away but he tied
him up in
how about
mike myers what a nice run he is on and
he comes in and punches out the side
in the bottom of the eighth well it's up
to the captain mayfield has an rbi hit
he's one for three
[Music]
that's high they are loaded and it's
adele who will come to the plate
it's a big moment for joe adel though i
think it's the right decision to give
joe adele an opportunity to swing the
bat
1-1
adele left field that ball's deep
that ball's gone
grand slam the kid did it
and the angels grab the lead say it is
so joe
and now
grant slam given the opportunity
joe madden the trust in the youngster
and he did not disappoint
suzuki now
suzuki left field
castro back that one's gone back to back
aloha
kurt suzuki a slam
and a solo and a 7-2 lead
wow
some noise
ligaris now
legarres the left and that's going to
get to the wall
and he's gonna get to second
power arm after power arm has come out
of the pen
now bring fletcher up he started things
fletcher and that gets under the glove
of scope
and that's gonna mean another run as
lagarus comes in
eight to two
ground ball oh yeah it's fletch
fittingly to first what a night for the
angels tonight in detroit
boy be able to come back like they did
against a power arm like soto grand slam
by joe adele big game by brandon marsh
and the glove
no more gary payton we're going david
fletcher the glow
very nice
you